welcome to this video playing blitz game
Gary kyun from France to 484 high rating
let's see what happens some four nights
right let's go for 95 check to take I
recently it was this is the same guy i
recently lost the game with with this
capture with GTA's maybe the same the
same player cannot remember yeah
ok I'd like to tell you that
we are still Bishop a bit tricky this
position we go d6 this Bishop g5 with a
really ugly pin yeah this is somewhat
annoying this line I need to look that
up or maybe flick just rewatch my own
video where why I recommended Bishop c5
on you for which is really a better a
better line that than this but i forgot
to what I what I presented in the video
okay I'll take two to play d5 either
shouldn't be too bad for me
looks like fairly solid position getting
counterplay in the center yeah but
surprising that he didn't take cool down
but take with maybe I should take with
the night I'm not sir I don't want to
happen to spend long time here go King
evade this Bishop h6 i'm not sure about
that but then on Bishop b5 I'm just
going night Bishop d7
I think this would be okay for me
yeah I think he could he could could
play Bishop b5 maybe i'll be sure g5 but
I just canceled I don't really think
that the shot should be threatening
hmm interesting okay yeah this is so
this is how to believe actually okay but
take it yeah of course just the details
and then the Queen
hmm I don't really I don't really
believe that this should work but maybe
it does okay that's I just I just need
to he just needs to show me it's
dangerous I mean it's not like it's
completely ridiculous but I didn't
didn't really believe it okay and I also
didn't see that move to bit but annoying
I can't play button to a five but then I
always thought I have micholi 62 to
block block the e-file and now this is
obviously not on
didn't didn't see any other ya know
maybe I shouldn't have taken I mean I
was perfectly alright if I don't take C
form but still I didn't yeah I didn't
really see Brooke she fine hmm yeah yeah
still what what does this move now
Bishop d6 yeah
yeah I move like windy ages so probably
not helping and I GA to serve very very
passive
can I g8 not really Queen d8 this maybe
not be five everybody yeah I need to I
need to move that some at some point
hmm yeah this was unnecessary what I
came roped you for I didn't I didn't see
okay but what am i threatening him a
threatening something i'm mary king of
aid getting out of the pin and maybe we
should be six
if he goes if he goes tonight be five
what am I going to play maybe just King
evade
not sure it's the best but not much time
hmm
check should befall check yeah Black is
winning here matter of time can you
Castle time morning
Bishop f5 is the threat and need to be
quick in check check check check first
getting all the pawns to at least secure
drawls check check check mate Wow poo
and no idea what was going on there
maybe it was a loss someone somewhere he
had a huge attack I didn't really see
how he could could win but this is
probably who okay so we cancelled him
cool mean what i was talking about I
could I could just castle him he am I
maybe can take him something like this
yeah something like this now we're white
is better I mean it so it sits opposite
colored bishops but this is such a
monster hmm chan wrong castles is
probably strong okay I took it and this
one might be five is strong computer
points out the smooth put them this
check where this is very strong winning
probably and this is also very dangerous
and TM night b5 seems to seems to yeah
seems to win what can you do it it seems
so okay I thought this would be possible
but white can play play this wow that is
a strong at this coming
check check this kind of stuff yeah okay
so he really should have should have won
this but it's difficult for both sides
here yeah I read just repeated moves
because I didn't have any time there
should be six is strong here probably
saving after this there's still the wind
possible and then you event with this
and this is not not really working it's
a looking spectacular chatter I'm not
not really working check because of this
this fork and then okay the time was
some was a problem of course but it's
it's basically just a look oh here
missed him mister mate i miss the medium
check yes check this was an immediate
mate checkmate okay 18 seconds I only
saw that here at best can can check me
Jen ones take it I thought this one yeah
what's the winds okay so very very lucky
when I'm gonna try to defend tenaciously
but it was just winning a tech and I
need to check those opening ready okay
thanks for watching